it used to be the clocks had faces on
them their analog clocks their unknown
today but your occasional you find one
and you look at it you haven't least I
have an immediate question of hey if
it's known how long will it be you know
these are lined up how long will it be
until they're lined up begin
well not it's more than an hour but you
know how long until you know just at
exactly what time will the clock hands
line up okay a little bit after 1:00
it'll line up and line up again a little
bit after - so what's the time
difference between there you know how
many you say well it's more than an hour
how can I figure that one out I'm
sitting there saying yeah you know I
remember sitting in a fifth-grade
classroom trying to figure it out
drawing diagrams and thinking boy I need
to add a little bit more a little bit
more little just it's going to be a
little bit more than that scurvy and
then you know it's going to be more than
that more than that how much how much
time in two and then like you I realized
though there's a simple way to solve it
let's go back to noon how many times do
these hands cross in 12 hours
well there's once twice three times and
so on in fact think about it you'll
realize the hands cross each other
11 times every 12 hours
ah if there's 11 hand crossings every 12
hours that means that they will cross
each other so that means how long will
it take for between here
to here that must be 12 / 11 hours which
happens to be 1 hour 5 minutes and 27
something seconds my clock is almost out
of potential energy so I might as well
wind it up Oh recharge my old test
Thomas for a week thanks for watching
this numberphile video you may not know
actually run another channel called
objectivity and in each episode we look
at a different science treasure it could
be things like Isaac Newton's death-mask
these treasure trunks with secret hidden
locks or things like this or this or
these you never know what you're going
to get in fact this week the video is
about clocks and there's a few more
clock videos coming soon as well we've
done over a hundred videos there's new
ones every week if you'd like to check
it out there are links on the screen and
in the video description I'd love it if
you subscribe thanks for watching